that day was very very bad because i
so i woke up at like six from the phone
ringing
and then
and i first didn't i like i was totally
cool with the heck in a sense before i
realized first of all before i
um realized that there can be a
narrative that i hacked myself which i
didn't think is a thing but apparently
it can be and also it was pushed by ph
all the time and because of this issue
we had with him before so
it was kind of unpleasant uh
it turned unpleasant it wasn't at first
i didn't bother because i was thinking
i'm quite lucky that
i have nothing to hide
and uh
like imagine i had something i don't
know that i did bad and i wrote someone
in dms and it leaks and then you know
because this leaks the problem usually
not the clicks the problem is what licks
here
but fortunately i had nothing to hide
and so the hacker started editing
messages because there was nothing in
there
and trying to put other people in bad
light i i thought it would be all fine
because anyway nobody takes it seriously
but uh so i first i found out that yeah
ph didn't like that
and just me saying to him that
i was hacked i never accused you of
anything of course um
other than the jordan thing
which makes it very strange because i
cannot just say i never accuse you of
anything
because like again i don't accuse him of
that i mean it's like already what
accused i mean i didn't like it but
that's it i'm moving on it's not like
i'm never like i'm i didn't like it and
we move on just i want to clear have it
clear i didn't like it that's it but uh
so that kind of sounds stupid